H ere with her thoughts
on Women's History Month
is Nightly Show contributor
Robin Thede.
-(applause and cheering)
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Welcome to the show, Robin.
-Thanks, Larry.
Now for Women's History Month,
I just wanted to shed light
on a phenomenon that can help
people understand women better.
Oh, that's great.
Uh, what is it?
Black lady sign language.
-(whooshing)
-(laughter)
-There it is.
-Wow.
Okay, this is kind of cool.
So what is black lady
sign language then?
Well, you might have noticed
-that black ladies use a lot
of hand gestures. -Right.
-You know, non-verbal
communication. -Right.
Chances are there's a black lady
in your office,
-and she's probably named
Rhonda. -Mm-hmm. -(laughter)
And you might misunderstand
her sometimes, right?
Like, you might think Rhonda's
being hostile when she's not,
or you might think she's not
being hostile when she is.
-(laughter) -Oh, wow. I can see
how that would be problematic.
-Right.
-Yes.
So, think of this as my public
service announcement
so you can understand Rhonda
a little bit better.
-That's great. Okay, so how does
it work? - Yeah. Okay.
-All right, let me give you
a few examples. -All right.
Number one--
the single hand clap.
-(whooshing)
-All right.
-Now this can be used to express
happiness or anger. -Mm-hmm.
And learning
to tell the difference
can actually save your life.
All right, watch.
-Oh, okay, great, great. Okay.
-All right.
-Oh, it's my song!
-(applause and cheering)
-Oh.
-Right? Right?
Wow. Okay.
It's very different from,
"Bitch, what'd you say to me?"
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
WILMORE:
Okay.
Uh, uh, uh, I know. At first
glance, they can look the same.
-But weren't those the same?
-No, no, no.
-No, no, not at all, Larry.
-Oh. Okay.
Now, here, just watch it
in slow motion.
-All right.
(slowly):
My... song.
-WILMORE: Okay.
-Versus...
(slowly):
"Bitch... what?!
(laughter)
See, the finger roll is
the subtle difference. Yup.
-Oh, my God!
-Yup.
I would never know
to look for that thing.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-It's the finger thing.
That's right.
Now you will.
-Now you will.
-Wow. That's fascinating.
-Black lady sign language.
-Thank you. All right.
All right, well, let's move on
to our next gesture, okay?
-Sure. Okay.
-This is the double hand clap
-versus the double hand clap
on syllables. -Mm-hmm.
-(whooshing)
-All right. -Okay.
Now, this one's easier to spot,
but it can be deceptive.
-Right. Okay. All right.
-So check this out. All right.
Yay! Great job
on your performance.
-Oh. Yeah, that's good. Yeah.
-Yeah.
See, that-that just looks
like regular applause, right?
-Well, that's correct,
because it is. -Oh, okay.
But compare that to the double
hand clap on syllables.
WILMORE:
Syllables, okay.
-What did you say to me, Larry?
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Um...
I didn't... I didn't
say anything. I was just...
Don't interrupt me, Larry.
-(applause and cheering)
-All right.
-I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding. -Oh. Oh.
-Okay.
But now you can see how
effective it is, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Oh, wow. Yeah.
-Man, I was... I was scared.
Yeah. -The double... Yeah.
The double hand clap
on syllables is used
to emphasizes a point. Yes.
-Wow. That was so effective,
Robin. -Yeah.
That's, um... It really
emphasizes an angry point.
-Right? Uh-huh. -Oh, yeah, well,
not necessarily.
-Oh, okay.
-It's tricky because
it can be used
for anger or excitement.
Such as, "Oh, my God,
these shoes are on sale!"
-(laughter, cheering)
-You got it. You got it, yeah.
Nice! That's crazy, man.
That's great.
Okay, now, we're only...
we're allowed to do that.
-(laughter)
-Oh. Oh, I'm sorry. Okay.
It's cool, but, uh,
don't let it happen again.
-(laughter)
-All right. -Okay.
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah. -Got it. Got it.
-Okay.
-Got it.
All right, so,
time for our final
-black lady sign language
gesture. -Okay.
-Now, this-this is a big one.
-Mm-hmm.
The double hand wave versus
the double hand wave pullback.
-Mm-hmm. Ooh.
-(whooshing)
Wow. That sounds complicated.
-It is complicated.
-Okay.
-But you've been doing well
so far. -Okay.
So, all right, let's start
with the double hand wave.
-Okay, double hand wave.
-All right, all right.
-So, see, I'm just waving
both hands. -Oh.
Just double hand wave. Hi!
It's cute, right?
-Oh. Oh, yeah, I like that.
That's good. -Say hi!
-Yeah. Hey! Hey!
-Right? Right? Right? Right?
-Great.
-Yeah, that's nice.
-But if I do the double
hand wave pullback... -Okay.
Who said what to me?
(applause and cheering)
(Wilmore clears his throat)
See-see this is a woman
who's at her wit's end.
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-She's not in a space to reason.
-You should probably leave
the room. -Wow. -(laughter)
I think I saw that on WorldStar
once, that double thing.
-Yes. -Yeah.
-(laughter)
-Absolutely. Very good. -It was
very... It was a scary moment.
-Yeah. Okay. -It... Yes, no,
it can be quite a thing.
All right, well, so, let's
wrap this up by showing you
-all three in action, all right?
-Oh, great.
This is what I like to call
-the black lady sign language
combo platter. -(whooshing)
All right, to better understand
the wonderful black ladies
in your life,
you have to pay attention
and say good-bye to all
your preconceived notions.
And if you ever get confused,
just rewatch this segment.
-(applause and cheering)
-Do you hear me, Larry?
-Yes, yes.
-Okay.
I hear you. Robin Thede,
everybody. We'll right back.